How to revitalize the Japanese economy Do
n't buy cars from Big Motors Don't get Sopo insurance It's
about time to
buy Godzilla, who regularly comes to destroy Tokyo Introduce a shadow clone tax
Well, Konoha will collapse.
But please protect Mr. Miyamoto no matter what, never let
director Miyazaki retire,
throw all the subsidies that have been given to Toyota into From Software, and
needless to say, please make Bloodborne 2.
Sending electromagnetic equipment into areas where there is a shortage of carpenters. Occasionally
voting for a party other than the Liberal Democratic Party. If it's on the same line,
announcing the demarcation of Pokemon. Putting
1,000 yen into an investment fund every time you buy a souvenir.
Within a year, the people  I hope Mr.
Nissin, who will make everyone millionaires, develops a line diagram next time.We
can definitely buy it.Secretly
double the caffeine content of all green tea products.Tell
middle school students that YouTube is
not a proper job.  I'd be hurt if
I quit.I think it would be interesting to create a sequel to Takumi Fujiwara and his 86, the Initial D, which uses unrivaled guts and genius
technology to overcome the overwhelming power of overseas
electric cars.
Create a law that makes it easier to catch troublesome YouTubers so that they
don't have to spend money on unnecessary operations. No, I'm not a troublemaker. Change the 100 yen yen nationwide
to 200 yen. This country is supported by
politics.  It's not the house, it's Daiso and Celia's product. It's
time for the development department to be more grateful to them. The
tunnel digging is all done by 5-jo Satoru.
Komurasaki, a small picture to celebrate the trust between oneself and others,
is culture.  Introducing it to the West and
lowering its efficiency.
ONE Continue
studying even after going to university.
Introducing Uber as soon as possible. Adding AI technology to products. It
's not for me.
And the country's birth rate will further decline.
If that's the case, then it's time to make more animated commercials for Mac.It's time to give
mappers a
break.No one can do a good job without taking a break.Maybe mappers
also
made that animated commercial for Mac.A
banking app that won't irritate you.  Develop
strong separation properly.
Make more Gundams. Have SEGA use all the tax money currently being spent on the Osaka Kansai Expo to
make Dreamcast 2. Wow, I
got goosebumps just saying that.
DET